From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. And of course, every week here, we try to describe and understand the world by listening to all kinds of people that we interview, and to reporters, and writers. And it's occurred to us lately that maybe this is wrongheaded. Maybe if we want real understanding, real explanations, we need to turn to science.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目。当然，我们每周都会通过采访各类人士、记者和作家，来尝试描述和理解这个世界。但我们最近想到，这种做法可能走进了误区。如果想要真正的理解和解释，也许我们需要转向科学。
Consider this story, lab partners. When Dennis was a kid, his stepfather always thought that wherever they lived was lousy. He thought the only place worth living in was New York City. This is a man, by the way, who had grown up in a town of a few thousand in Indiana.
来看看这个关于室友的故事。丹尼斯小时候，他的继父总觉得无论他们住在哪里都很糟糕。他认为世界上唯一值得居住的地方就是纽约市。顺便说一下，这个男人是在印第安纳州一个几千人的小镇长大的。
You know, he loves his symphony and opera, and art movies, and he just-- he never felt like he fit. He thought that there are people in New York who all loved classical music and love to read. And he would just show up and say smart things, and that people would say, well, Mr. Kass, it's so-- we are so glad you are here.
你知道，他热爱交响乐、歌剧和艺术电影，只是……他总觉得格格不入。他以为纽约人也都热爱古典音乐和阅读。他觉得只要自己出现在那里，发表一些睿智的见解，人们就会说：“噢，卡斯先生，我们真高兴您能来。”
And so they moved to New York, the whole family, when Dennis was 12.
于是，在丹尼斯 12 岁那年，全家人搬到了纽约。
It was awful. I mean, it was a disaster from the moment we touched down. None of the elements that he had fantasized about were there. I think we went to the symphony once. It's expensive.
结果糟透了。我的意思是，从我们落地的那一刻起就是一场灾难。他幻想的那些元素一个都没有。我想我们只去过一次交响乐团，因为太贵了。
I mean, just the pace of the city and the competitiveness of it, he just couldn't-- he couldn't handle it. He just couldn't handle it. During that first year, he started breaking out in hives, covered in hives from head to toe-- essentially, an allergic reaction to his life in New York.
我是说，光是城市那种节奏和竞争感，他就完全无法应对。他就是承受不了。第一年里，他开始全身起荨麻疹，从头到脚全是——本质上，这是他对纽约生活产生的过敏反应。
Now, science can help us understand this story. There's a notion in physics called the mediocrity principle. It requires that no place in the universe is more special than any other place.
现在，科学可以帮助我们理解这个故事。物理学中有一个概念叫“平庸原理”。它主张宇宙中没有任何地方比其他任何地方更特殊。
The ancients, remember, thought that we are at the center of the universe. The sun and the stars revolved around us. Mediocrity principle says, no, no, that's wrong.
记得吗，古人认为我们处于宇宙的中心，太阳和星星都围绕着我们旋转。而平庸原理说，不，不，那是错的。
No place is special. And there's nothing special about us. Dennis says, by the way, that all this was obvious to him, even when he was 12, back when his stepdad was itching to move to New York.
没有哪个地方是特殊的，我们也没有什么特殊之处。顺便说一下，丹尼斯说，即使在 12 岁时，当他继父迫不及待想搬去纽约时，这一切对他来说就已经显而易见了。
When I first heard about the mediocrity principle, it made me really happy. I almost felt like I had discovered a law of science, as a 12-year-old, all by myself.
当我第一次听说平庸原理时，我感到非常高兴。我甚至觉得自己像是一个 12 岁的孩子，凭一己之力发现了一条科学定律。
How so?
怎么说呢？
Because when you think about the fact that where you are is not really different than anywhere else you could be, you don't have to move.
因为当你想到你所在的地方和你可能去的任何地方并没有什么不同时，你就不必搬家了。
What can the laws of physics tell us about our everyday lives? Consider, please, this experiment in human relations. Kitty and Lars each needed a roommate. They got a place together on July 1.
物理定律能告诉我们关于日常生活的什么信息呢？请看看这个关于人际关系的实验。基蒂和拉斯都需要合租室友。7 月 1 日，他们住到了一起。
By July 28, it was clear to both of them they should be more than just roommates. By August 3, Lars had told Kitty that he wanted to marry her. They've been together for years now. They are incredibly happy. And they both say that if they hadn't actually lived together as roommates, if they'd only dated, it never would have worked out.
到了 7 月 28 日，两人都很清楚，他们的关系应该超越室友。8 月 3 日，拉斯告诉基蒂他想娶她。他们在一起已经很多年了，非常幸福。他们都说，如果他们当初没有真正住在一起，如果只是单纯约会，这段感情可能根本不会成功。
Probably not.
可能不会。
Yeah, probably not. We wouldn't have spent that much time with each other. I mean, the weekends, we would spend pretty much the entire days with each other. And we're pretty different people.
是的，可能不会。我们不会花那么多时间在一起。我是说，周末的时候，我们几乎整天都待在一起。而且我们是性格相当不同的人。
Right.
对。
And I'm not your type. I mean, I think you're a little bit more my type, but you've always said that I was never your type.
而且我不是你的理想型。我是说，我觉得你更符合我的标准，但你总是说我从来不是你的理想型。
[LAUGHS] I also don't think we would have stayed together necessarily had we not been living together. I think it definitely helped to just force us to work things out.
[笑] 我也不觉得如果我们没有住在一起，我们就一定会在一起。我认为住在一起确实迫使我们去解决问题。
What can science tell us about this? OK, well, in physics, there's something called the Casimir Effect. It says that there's an attractive force between objects that are in proximity to each other.
科学能告诉我们什么呢？好吧，在物理学中，有一种东西叫“卡西米尔效应”。它指出，处于邻近位置的物体之间存在一种吸引力。
Hendrik Casimir was talking about two uncharged plates, close to each other in a vacuum. It's a very faint sort of force. And a very faint sort of force was all that Lars and Kitty felt for each other at first.
亨德里克·卡西米尔讨论的是真空中相互靠近的两个不带电板。这是一种非常微弱的力。而拉斯和基蒂最初对彼此的感觉，也正是那种非常微弱的力。
I mean, it kind of just crept up on me. I mean, we were spending lots of time together, and towards the end, we were flirting and whatnot. But it really didn't quite dawn on me until, you know, we were on the couch kissing.
我是说，这种感觉就像是悄悄滋生出来的。我们在一起花了很多时间，最后阶段，我们在调情等等。但这直到我们在沙发上亲吻时，我才真正意识到。
Even the night that we actually hooked up or whatever, I remember what we were doing. We were watching A Clockwork Orange, which is not the most romantic movie. I wouldn't have been playing that movie, had I thought we'd be getting together that night. So yeah, and it's the most violent, misogynistic movie ever made, and yet we still-- we fell in love over it. It's our movie.
甚至在我们正式在一起的那天晚上，我记得我们在做什么。我们在看《发条橙》，那可不是什么浪漫的电影。如果我知道那天晚上我们要在一起，我绝对不会放那部电影。所以，是的，那是史上最暴力、最厌女的电影，但我们还是——我们因它坠入爱河。那是我们的电影。
Yup. [LAUGHS]
没错。[笑]
Yeah, that is a strong feeling of romance, to overcome that barrier.
是啊，克服了那种障碍，那确实是一种强烈的浪漫感。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, it still kind of creeps me out a little bit.
嗯，这还是让我觉得有点毛骨悚然。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm a little embarrassed about that part.
对此我感到有点尴尬。
Right, but that proves how inevitable-- I mean, if you can make lovey eyes at each other during that movie, there's no stopping us.
对，但这证明了这种必然性——我的意思是，如果你能在看那部电影时对彼此含情脉脉，那就没有什么能阻挡我们了。
Now, I need to acknowledge that physicists hate it-- they hate it, they hate it-- when non-scientists do this, when we non-scientists take scientific laws and principles intended for a very different purpose in context, and apply them to ourselves and our petty little relationships with each other. Witness, please, the attitude of Dave Kestenbaum, PhD, who used to be a high-energy experimental particle physicist on the team that discovered the top quark at Fermilab. He's now one of our colleagues on the radio.
现在，我得承认，物理学家们讨厌这一点——他们真的很讨厌，当非专业人士这样做时。当非科学家的我们取用科学定律和原则，用于完全不同的语境，并应用到我们自己琐碎的感情生活上时，他们会很反感。请看戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆博士的态度，他曾是费米实验室发现顶夸克团队中的高能实验粒子物理学家。现在他是我们在电台的同事之一。
It's a bad idea. You know, every artist at some point in their lives goes and reads a little book on quantum mechanics, or they hear about Schrodinger's cat or the uncertainty principle or something like that. And then they go write a really bad play. [LAUGHS] And it's inevitably terrible. You know, people who don't know a lot of physics seem to like it, but I get a little bugged by it, I have to say.
这是个坏主意。你知道，每个艺术家在人生某个阶段都会读一点关于量子力学的书，或者听说过“薛定谔的猫”或“不确定性原理”之类的东西。然后他们去写了一出非常烂的戏。[笑] 那绝对是糟糕透顶的。你知道，不懂物理的人似乎很喜欢这些，但我得说，这让我有点困扰。
OK, I have to say, that seems entirely reasonable. But we at This American Life-- we just do not care. Our feeling is, once a physicist names something the mediocrity principle, or the uncertainty principle, or the grandfather paradox, basically, they're asking for it.
好吧，我得说，这听起来完全合理。但我们《美国生活》——我们根本不在乎。我们的感觉是，既然物理学家把某个东西命名为“平庸原理”、“不确定性原理”或“祖父悖论”，那他们本质上就是在自找麻烦。
The mediocrity principle prances into the lives of us non-scientists, all provocative with that all-provocative name, and what, we're not supposed to give that a second glance? We're supposed to stop our brains from instantly seeing that and all these other rules as metaphors to apply hither and thither, wherever we will? Today on our radio program, we ignore the pleas of reasonable people like Dave Kestenbaum and the silent screams of every physicist listening to our program right this moment, and bring you several stories, each one about everyday people in everyday situations, each one illuminated by some scientific law.
平庸原理以那个极具挑衅性的名字大摇大摆地走进我们这些非科学家的生活，难道我们就不该多看一眼吗？我们难道应该阻止大脑将这些规则作为隐喻，随意地应用到各处吗？今天在我们的广播节目中，我们无视像戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆这样理智之人的恳求，无视此刻正在收听我们节目的每一位物理学家心中的无声尖叫，为大家带来几个故事。每个故事都关于普通人在普通情境下的经历，而每一个故事都因某种科学定律而得到启发。
It's Family Physics. Our program today in three acts-- Act One, Occam's Razor; Act Two, The Trajectory and Force of Bodies in Orbit; Act Three, Conservation of Energy and Matter. In that act, by the way, we have a story by David Sedaris. Put on your safety goggles and white coats, my friends, and stay with us.
这就是“家庭物理学”。我们今天的节目分为三幕——第一幕，奥卡姆剃刀；第二幕，轨道中物体的轨迹与力；第三幕，能量与物质守恒。顺便说一下，这一幕我们有大卫·塞达里斯的故事。戴上你的护目镜和白大褂，朋友们，和我们一起看下去吧。
Act One, Occam's Razor. OK, this is a story about a family that had one theory about how to explain their lives. And then, at some point, that theory came to seem inadequate.
第一幕，奥卡姆剃刀。这是一个关于一个家庭的故事，他们曾有一个理论来解释自己的生活。后来在某个时候，那个理论似乎变得不适用了。
It did not seem to explain the data and evidence before them. And they switched to a different theory. Cris Beam tells the story in Los Angeles.
它似乎无法解释他们面前的数据和证据。于是他们换了一个理论。克里斯·比姆在洛杉矶讲述这个故事。
David Paladino grew up in an Italian family in an Italian neighborhood west of Chicago. It was the kind of place where, in the early '70s, all the kids wore Italian colors, ate Italian beef and sausage from the corner store, and threw money at the Virgin Mary statue at the Feast of Our Lady of Mount Carmel. But while David is Italian, too, he has many childhood stories about things people said to him that just didn't make any sense.
大卫·帕拉迪诺在一个意大利裔社区长大，那个社区位于芝加哥以西。在 70 年代初，那里的孩子们都穿着意大利色彩的衣服，吃着街角商店的意大利牛肉和香肠，在圣母圣衣节向圣母玛利亚像捐钱。但尽管大卫也是意大利裔，他却有很多关于人们对他说的那些完全讲不通的话的童年故事。
In Sunday school, the other kids called Dave, "Chocolate Bar" and "Blackie." People asked him who is real father was. When he went into stores, the clerks would sometimes follow him around as if he was going to steal something.
在主日学校，其他孩子叫戴夫“巧克力棒”和“小黑鬼”。人们问他谁是亲生父亲。当他走进商店时，店员有时会跟着他，仿佛他要偷东西一样。
When David was 10, his family moved into a townhouse in a more integrated area. Dave went out to play in a nearby playground.
大卫 10 岁那年，他们一家搬到了一个更加种族融合地区的联排别墅。戴夫去附近的游乐场玩。
This kid was there playing. He was a young Black kid, and he starts talking to me. And you know, he was much more outgoing than I was. He was asking me questions.
有个孩子在那里玩。他是个年轻的黑人孩子，开始和我聊天。你知道，他比我外向得多。他一直在问我问题。
And he was like, oh, do you curse, you know, and [INAUDIBLE] I'm like, no, I don't swear. My mom would kill me. You know, so and he's like, yeah, well, I do. I don't care.
他问我：“嘿，你骂人吗？”你知道，我回答：“不，我不说脏话。我妈会杀了我。”你知道，他回道：“是吗，我骂。我不在乎。”
So we're having a good time, and I was like, yeah, you want to see my place? He's like, yeah, so we walk. It's, like, a minute away. And so we're walking around the back yard area.
我们玩得很开心，我就说：“你想去我家看看吗？”他答应了。我家只有一分钟路程。于是我们在后院区域走动。
There's these tall hedges, and then there's the sliding glass door. So as we walk around these tall hedges in the backyard, my two sisters are coming out-- Lori and Shari. And so we walk around the corner, and he stops dead in his tracks, and he's like, what them white girls doing in your house?
那里有高高的树篱，还有一道滑动玻璃门。就在我们绕过树篱时，我的两个姐妹洛瑞和莎莉走了出来。我们转过拐角，他突然停住脚步，问道：“你家那两个白人女孩是谁？”
And I was like, white girls? Those are my sisters. And he's like, your sisters? And I'm like, yeah. And then, all of a sudden, my mom comes out, and my dad is, like, right behind her. He's like, oh, Davey! Who is your friend?
我说：“白人女孩？那是我的姐妹。”他说：“你的姐妹？”我说：“是啊。”这时，我妈出来了，我爸就在她身后。他喊道：“噢，戴维！那是你的朋友吗？”
And he's like, who's that? I said, oh, that's my mom. And he's like, your mom? And then my dad is right there. I'm like, oh, that's my dad. He's like, your dad? And he, like, looks at me, and then he looks at them, and he's like, oh, man! And he left! (LAUGHING) He left!
他问：“那是谁？”我说：“哦，那是我妈。”他说：“你妈？”然后我爸就在那儿。我说：“噢，那是我爸。”他问：“你爸？”他看着我，又看看他们，然后说了句：“噢，天哪！”他就跑了！（大笑）他跑了！
Strangely enough, we all had a little laugh about it. And then, it was just like everybody went their own direction, and nobody talked about it. But in retrospect, looking back on it, it's like, there was probably something there to be discussed, you know. And that put me in more mystery, I guess, about, oh, this is-- oh, yeah, I guess I am different.
奇怪的是，我们都为此笑了一下。然后大家就各走各的，谁也没再提这件事。但事后回想起来，当时可能确实有些事值得讨论。这让我更加困惑，我想，噢，这是——噢，是的，我猜我确实与众不同。
Carol and I met in high school. She was in Provenzano, and I was Paladino, so we were two seats, three seats apart in homeroom.
我和卡罗尔是在高中认识的。她是普罗文扎诺家的，我是帕拉迪诺家的，所以在自修室里我们只隔了两个座位。
This is Dave Paladino's father, David Paladino, Sr.
这是戴夫·帕拉迪诺的父亲，老戴维·帕拉迪诺。
Big snowfall in 1967, and we were at a party. And we were at some kid's basement, and there was music playing, and we met down in the basement. We talked for about an hour, and we went out and played in the snow, and then we went back downstairs and made out.
1967 年的一场大雪，我们在一个派对上。我们在某个孩子的地下室，播放着音乐，我们在地下室相遇。我们聊了一个小时，然后出去在雪地里玩，接着回到楼下亲热。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then, after that, it was-- we were boyfriend and girlfriend for end of sophomore year, junior year, senior year.
在那之后，我们从高二下学期、高三、高四一直保持着男女朋友关系。
David and Dave's mom, Carol, went to high school in a neighborhood on Chicago's West Side, called Maywood. In 1968, their junior year, race riots broke out in their school, making national headlines. Kids were pulling guns on each other, and the National Guard was called in.
大卫和戴夫的母亲卡罗尔是在芝加哥西区一个叫梅伍德的社区读的高中。1968 年，他们高三那年，学校爆发了种族骚乱，登上了全国头条。孩子们互相掏枪，国民警卫队被召集入场。
During this time, David and Carol were dating. They didn't participate in the riots. In fact, Dave was vice president of his senior class, and Carol was a cheerleader. And they were both involved in the student leadership's efforts towards racial harmony.
这段时间，大卫和卡罗尔在约会。他们没有参与骚乱。事实上，戴夫是高年级班级的副主席，卡罗尔是拉拉队长。他们都参与了学生领导层为种族和解所做的努力。
We were trying to mix the races a bit, as far as getting along and meet each other. Where before, it would just be all white people, you know, at our parties, and Black kids would all have their parties, but we actually had some crossover things going on, where Black students were coming into our parties.
我们试图让种族稍微融合一点，让大家相处和了解彼此。以前，我们的派对上全是白人，你知道，黑人学生也会有自己的派对，但我们实际上做了一些跨界的事情，让黑人学生也来参加我们的聚会。
And I remember we had some Black kids come to one of our whatever guys' houses one night, and they taught us, like, how to do the Boogaloo dance and all this-- (LAUGHING) that time, so I remember dancing the Boogaloo.
我记得有一天晚上有一些黑人孩子来了我们其中一个男孩家里，他们教我们怎么跳布加鲁舞之类的——（大笑）那时候，所以我记得跳过布加鲁舞。
Actually, the role that I played at the high school, I was on, quotes, "Cross-Section Committee"--
实际上，我在高中的角色是“跨界委员会”的成员——
This is Dave's mom, Carol.
这是戴夫的妈妈卡罗尔。
--which were Blacks and whites. And we were supposed to come up with new ways to try to bring some semblance of normalcy into the high school, like kind of make it so that there wasn't a problem between Blacks and whites.
——成员包括黑人和白人。我们的任务是想出新方法，试图为高中带来某种正常感，让黑人和白人之间不再有问题。
I started hanging out more with the girls that hung out with Black people. That's the best way I think I can say it. And so what would happen after basketball games was, we wouldn't go hang with the white guys. We'd go find out where the party where the Black guys were.
我开始更多地和那些与黑人相处的女孩待在一起。我想这是我能表达的最好方式。所以篮球赛后，我们不会去和白人男孩混在一起，而是去打听黑人男孩开派对的地方。
And you know, for me, it was seeing a different culture. I can remember it then. Because these gals grew up differently than I grew up. And so it was just me having a different level of understanding. And of course, being the liberal that I was then, it was like this all felt right.
对我来说，那是去见识一种不同的文化。我现在还记得。因为这些女孩成长的环境和我不同。这让我有了一种不同的理解层面。当然，作为当时那个自由派的我，这感觉是对的。
The big word was that some of the cheerleaders were sleeping with the basketball team. And then, I had several people come up to me and tell me that Carol had-- was kissing some of the players, and other things were going on. But I knew something had happened, but I didn't know what had happened.
当时流言蜚语说一些拉拉队员和篮球队员睡在一起。随后，有几个人跑来告诉我卡罗尔一直在和一些球员接吻，还有其他事情发生。我知道发生了什么，但我不知道具体是什么。
It was just dangerous fun for me, OK? And then, somebody-- and I'm not sure what or how it happened, but somebody had seen me hanging out with a bunch of Black kids after a basketball game. And it was my mother's brother, my Uncle Frankie, that had heard it from one of his friends.
那对我来说只是危险的乐趣，懂吗？然后，某个人——我不确定是什么时候、怎么发生的——有人看到我和一群黑人孩子在篮球赛后混在一起。是我母亲的兄弟，我叔叔弗兰基，从他的朋友那里听说的。
I think it was Tony Fioravanti or something. But anyway, he told my Uncle Frankie, and my Uncle Frankie told my mom and dad. And my mom and dad then said, what are you doing hanging out with Black kids?
我想那是托尼·菲奥拉万蒂还是谁。总之，他告诉了我叔叔弗兰基，我叔叔弗兰基又告诉了我爸妈。我爸妈问我：“你为什么和黑人孩子混在一起？”
They're going to call you a [BLEEP] lover, and we can't have that happen. So then, I used to sneak around. And the easiest way for me to sneak around was make sure that there were other white girls there.
“他们会叫你黑人情人，我们不能让这种事发生。”所以后来我就开始偷偷摸摸。我偷偷摸摸最简单的方法，就是确保有其他白人女孩在场。
At this point, Carol began seeing one basketball player in particular-- Keith Rash, a Black student one year behind her in school.
此时，卡罗尔开始和一个特定的篮球运动员交往——基思·拉什，一个比她低一年级的黑人学生。
I was hanging out with Keith, but I was also hanging out with Dave, you know. I was living the wild life. And let's see, I screwed around with both of them. That's about as plainly as I can say it.
我一边和基思鬼混，但也和戴夫待在一起，你知道的。我过着狂野的生活。让我们看看，我和他们俩都上过床。这就是我能说的最直白的话。
But the problem was that-- also, never really understanding how I could get pregnant, when I could get pregnant, or anything like that. So we used no form of birth control.
但问题在于——我也从不真正理解如何避孕、何时会怀孕，或者类似的事情。所以我们没有使用任何避孕手段。
Carol was actually four months along before she knew she was pregnant. She got the news from her family doctor a few weeks before Thanksgiving.
卡罗尔在怀孕四个月后才发现自己怀孕了。感恩节前几周，她从家庭医生那里得到了消息。
All of a sudden, the room just shut. Now, I don't remember if I heard everything he said past that point. Because now, my mind was, oh my god, who's the father? I had no idea.
突然间，房间仿佛静止了。我不记得在那之后他还说了什么。因为那时我的脑海里只有：天哪，谁是父亲？我根本不知道。
No one but Carol knew about Keith. But as Carol started to show, David assumed the baby was his. Now 18, and in their first semester at a nearby college, they decided to get married over the next school break.
除了卡罗尔没人知道基思的事。但随着卡罗尔显怀，大卫以为孩子是他的。那时他们 18 岁，在附近一所大学上大一，他们决定在下一个学校假期结婚。
Carol called her mom with the news. Mom screamed and immediately ran next door to gather Carol's grandparents, and then across the street to get her aunt and uncle. Within hours, everyone was assembled, and the patriarchs, David's father and Carol's father, had driven to the college to pick up the kids.
卡罗尔给母亲打了电话。母亲尖叫着跑进隔壁找卡罗尔的祖父母，又跑过马路去找姨妈和姨夫。几个小时内，所有人就集合完毕，族长们——大卫的父亲和卡罗尔的父亲——开车到大学把孩子们接了回来。
Her mother had an announcement. There would be no delaying this marriage. They were to get their blood tests and rings the next day, the wedding dress the following day, and they'd be married by the end of that weekend by the parish priest. Carol says they were both in shock.
她的母亲宣布了消息。婚礼不能延期。他们第二天必须去做血检并买戒指，后天去选婚纱，周末结束前由教区牧师主持婚礼。卡罗尔说他们俩都惊呆了。
OK, so then, Dave says-- you know, God bless him, really. 'Cause the truth is, to try to stand up to my parents, he said, but that's not what we planned. We want to wait, and we want to get married over Thanksgiving.
好吧，然后戴夫说——你知道，上帝保佑他，真的。因为真相是，为了反抗我父母，他说：“但这不是我们计划的。我们想等一等，我们想在感恩节结婚。”
My dad, he said, what do you mean you want to wait? He said, what's the matter? Don't you want to marry my daughter? And there was a pound on the table, too, you know.
我爸拍着桌子说：“你什么意思你想等？怎么了？你不想娶我女儿吗？”
This is the best shotgun wedding I can think of.
这是我能想到的最典型的奉子成婚。
[LAUGHTER IN BACKGROUND]
[背景笑声]
And totally Italian stuff. So if I ever thought that I was going to have a moment to confess anything, I knew right then it was gone. Absolutely gone. And from that moment on became a daily prayer.
全都是意大利式的东西。所以如果我曾想过哪怕有一刻可以坦白什么，我知道就在那一瞬间一切都没了。完全没了。从那一刻起，生活变成了每天的祈祷。
In my mind, I could see the baby coming out and being Black, and then everybody in the room going like this-- [GASPS] And then, me coming out and trying to tell Dave. So I go into labor, and I'm petrified, in pain and petrified.
在脑海里，我能看到孩子出生时是黑人，然后房间里的每个人都这样——（倒吸一口气）然后我站出来试着告诉戴夫。所以当我要分娩时，我被吓坏了，在痛苦和恐惧中。
And then, he comes out, and they show him to me, and he looked white to me. I mean, he had a whole bunch of black hair, but what baby didn't have a black hair? He had dark eyes, but what baby didn't have dark eyes?
然后，他出来了，他们给我看他。他看起来是白人。我的意思是，他有一头黑发，但哪个婴儿没有黑头发？他有深色的眼睛，但哪个婴儿没有深色眼睛？
And we had a lot of darkness in our family. I mean, but he didn't look Black. So I was like, oh, God, thank you, thank you, thank you.
我们家族有很多深色基因。但他看起来不像黑人。所以我说：“噢，上帝，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。”
First inkling of [INAUDIBLE] was probably when-- he was born in March. It was probably toward the end of that summer, because I was outside a lot with him. And when he was out in the sun, he got darker. And I was like, uh-oh.
第一次有预感大概是在——他三月出生。大概是那个夏天结束时，因为我经常带他在外面。当他在太阳下时，他变黑了。我想：“呃噢。”
At the married student apartments, we had a little swimming pool out front. And Davey was out, and he was out in the full sun, and he got-- [SNAPS] --brown like that, and immediately looked like he could have been a Black kid. You know, he was dark.
在已婚学生的公寓里，我们前面有个小游泳池。戴维在外面，他完全暴露在阳光下，结果——（清脆的响声）——他变得像那样棕黑，立刻看起来就像个黑人孩子。你知道，他很黑。
And then, I remember after that, we had gone shopping. And we had him in the cart, and we were wheeling him into a store. And this woman came out and followed us out into the parking lot after we were leaving the store, and she says, oh, wait, wait, wait. I wanted to talk to you.
然后我记得在那之后，我们去购物。我们把他放在购物车里，推进一家商店。有个女人跟出来，在我们离开商店后一直跟着我们到停车场，她说：“噢，等等，等等，等等。我想和你谈谈。”
And she said, I noticed that you and your wife have adopted an interracial baby. And you know, my husband and I are thinking of adopting an interracial baby. And I took it aback, like, what are you talking about?
她说：“我注意到你和你妻子领养了一个混血婴儿。你知道，我和我丈夫正考虑领养一个混血宝宝。”我吃了一惊，心想，你在说什么？
So I said, no, no, no. This is our baby. She said, I know it's your baby, but we're thinking adopting interracial babies. No, you don't understand. This is our baby.
我说：“不，不，不。这是我们的孩子。”她说：“我知道这是你的孩子，但我们正考虑领养混血宝宝。”“不，你不明白。这是我们的孩子。”
And she said, oh, well-- and then, finally, she understood what I was saying, you know. No, this is my wife and I's child, just dark, you know. That was an odd situation.
她说：“噢，好吧——”最后，她理解了我的意思，你知道的。不，这是我和我妻子的孩子，只是肤色深，你知道。那是种奇怪的情况。
What did that do in your mind? Did you think about it? Did you interrogate it? Did you--
那在你的脑海里引发了什么？你想过吗？你审视过它吗？你——
No, you see, I've had a lot of time to think about it since that. And I think what's interesting is that your mind-- this is-- if they have a belief system that they've put together, and they build their life on that belief system, that it's very hard for that belief system to be shook or changed by facts.
没有，你看，在那之后我有大把的时间去思考。我觉得有趣的是，你的大脑——这是——如果他们构建了一个信仰体系，并以此为基础生活，那么这个信仰体系就很难被事实所动摇或改变。
So I don't know how to say it, but I had a belief system that he was my son. I saw him born. I was there at the birth. I was there-- I was with his mother, and he was my son.
所以我不该怎么说，但我有一个信仰体系：他是我的儿子。我看着他出生。我当时就在产房。我当时——我和他的母亲在一起，他就是我的儿子。
So many times, I can tell you, we'd say the same story to anybody that would say-- especially when the two girls came along and they were so fair. They'd say, well, he doesn't look like the two girls.
我不知道多少次，我们可以告诉任何人同样的故事——特别是当两个女儿出生，她们那么白皙的时候。他们会问：“嗯，他长得不像那两个女孩。”
And we'd say, well, that's because he's got the olive skin from the family, you know. My grandfather's really olive-skinned. And you know, Dave's mother, she's German, but she's got this dark-black, curly hair, and he's got the same dark-black curly hair.
我们会说：“嗯，那是因为他遗传了家族的橄榄色皮肤，你知道。我祖父就是橄榄色皮肤。”你知道，戴夫的母亲，她是德国裔，但她有这种又黑又卷的头发，他也有同样又黑又卷的头发。
You know, I was a science teacher, so I wasn't, like, really stupid, OK? But I do know that our genetic makeup-- it's possible that you can have recessive genes and things that are in your system. It might skip a generation or two, and suddenly, you know, somebody looks like somebody that-- three generations ago, they look like someone.
你知道，我是个科学老师，所以我并没有那么笨，好吗？但我确实知道，我们的基因组成——有可能存在隐性基因和系统中的东西。它可能会跳过一两代，然后突然，你知道，某个人看起来像——三代前的那个人。
it's like, we're Italian, Paladino.
就好像，我们是意大利人，帕拉迪诺。
As David, Jr. got older, he was told the same stories inquisitive strangers were told.
随着小大卫长大，他被告知了和好奇的陌生人一样的故事。
You know, and my aunt was kind of dark-skinned over there, and they had black hair, and on my dad's side, they had this curly hair. But we-- I started to get these explainable things. Like, oh, I'm dark-skinned Italian, from the southern part of Italy, so there's also Sicilian-- Sicily is right there, and the Moors, and blah, blah, blah, and it is what it is.
你知道，我那边的姨妈肤色也挺深的，他们都有黑头发。我爸那边，他们有这种卷发。所以我开始得到这些可以解释的东西。比如，“哦，我是来自意大利南部的深肤色意大利人，那里也有西西里人——西西里就在那儿，还有摩尔人，巴拉巴拉，事实就是这样。”
Until his teens, Dave's family moved a lot, and he says every move was torture. His two sisters would just be asked the regular questions like, where are you from, and what music do you like. But Dave would be asked, who's your real dad, and were you adopted.
直到青少年时期，戴夫家搬了很多次，他说每次搬家都是折磨。他的两个姐妹只会问一些普通的问题，比如“你从哪儿来？”、“你喜欢什么音乐？”。但戴夫会被问：“谁是你亲生父亲？”、“你是领养的吗？”
So Dave learned to preempt the interrogations. He started wearing T-shirts with slogans like "Proud to be Italian," or "Another Italian masterpiece." And he would announce his heritage to anyone within moments of an introduction. And it wasn't just Dave. The whole family was in denial. Here's his mom.
所以戴夫学会了先发制人。他开始穿印有标语的 T 恤，比如“以意大利血统为荣”或“又一件意大利杰作”。他会在介绍自己后的片刻内向任何人宣布自己的血统。不仅仅是戴夫。整个家庭都在否认。这是他妈妈说的。
As David got older and his face started changing more, et cetera, and I dared to open up my yearbook and saw Keith, and then saw David, I was like, oh, God. And then, closed it shut, and said, I'll never look at that again.
随着大卫长大，他的脸部轮廓变化更多等等，我试着翻开毕业纪念册，看到基思，再看大卫，我想：“噢，上帝。”然后我赶紧合上，说：“我再也不看那个了。”
When he was 12, Dave and his family moved from Chicago to an upper-middle-class suburb of Los Angeles. And things went pretty smoothly there. Dave turned out to be a great football player, had a lot of friends and girlfriends, and after the initial surge of questions, issues of race or ethnicity, or what are you, just didn't come up too much.
12 岁时，戴夫和家人从芝加哥搬到了洛杉矶的中上层郊区。那里情况进展顺利。戴夫成了出色的足球运动员，有很多朋友和女朋友，在一开始的提问浪潮过后，关于种族、民族或“你是什么”的问题，就没再怎么出现了。
After high school, things got harder. His college, he says, was extremely white, and he just began to feel different. By now, he looked decidedly biracial. When he met white girlfriends' parents, they would sometimes shift uncomfortably.
高中毕业后，情况变得艰难。他说，他的大学极其排外，他开始感到与众不同。现在，他看起来明显是混血儿。当他见到白人女朋友的父母时，他们有时会感到局促不安。
He learned the phrase, person of color, and thought of himself as both a white person and a person of color, as if there were such a thing. If you saw David on the street, there's no way you'd think he was white. You'd think, biracial, or Puerto Rican, or Dominican.
他学会了“有色人种”这个词，并认为自己既是白人又是有色人种，仿佛真有这回事似的。如果你在街上看到大卫，你绝不会认为他是白人。你会认为他是混血儿、波多黎各人或多米尼加人。
He's very cute, with tight, soft, curly hair and light mocha-colored skin. By his mid-20s, David was starting to become an actor and go out on auditions. And the roles he was up for were almost always Black or Latin men.
他长得很可爱，留着紧致柔软的卷发，有着淡淡的摩卡色皮肤。20 多岁时，大卫开始成为一名演员并去参加试镜。他竞争的角色几乎总是黑人或拉丁裔男性。
One weekend, when he was in his late 20s, David took a trip to Chicago with one of his college friends, Aaron. They spent some time visiting David's family. They stayed downtown. They partied.
20 多岁时的一个周末，大卫和大学朋友亚伦一起去芝加哥旅行。他们花了一些时间拜访大卫的家人。他们住在市中心，去聚会。
And on their last night in Chicago, after David and Aaron had been drinking till 4:00 in the morning, they finally pulled up to their hotel.
在芝加哥的最后一晚，在大卫和亚伦喝到凌晨 4 点后，他们终于到达了酒店。
We got out of the cab, and there was a homeless guy there. And he's a Black man. He's probably in his 40s or something. And he, like, asked for some money, and I think I gave him $1 or something.
我们下了出租车，那里有个流浪汉。是个黑人，大概 40 多岁。他要些钱，我给了他一美元还是什么。
And Aaron gets out money like he's going to give it to him, and then he's like, well, I want to give this to you, you know, but I want to tell you something and kind of launches into this thing about, as long as you don't use this to use drugs or to do something, and starts to give him a little pep talk, he thought, a pep talk.
亚伦拿出了钱，好像要给那个人，然后他说：“嗯，我想给你这个，但我得告诉你点什么。”他开始说教，只要你不把这钱拿去买毒品或干坏事之类，就开始对他进行励志教育——他以为是励志教育。
And you know, but to me, it was insulting. The guy, I could just see the guy's whole demeanor just, like, oh, man, this guy. And we got in the elevator to go upstairs, I'm like, what are you doing?
但在我看来，那很侮辱人。那人的整个举止，我就能看出来，他心想：“噢，伙计，这家伙。”我们进电梯上楼时，我问：“你在干嘛？”
You know, like, he said, what do you mean? I said, give the guy $1 or give the guy $1. Don't give him your viewpoint. And he's like, well, if I'm going to give the guy $1, I'm going to say something.
他说：“什么意思？”我说：“给人家一美元就给一美元。别发表你的高见。”他说：“嗯，既然我要给他一美元，我就得说点什么。”
I said, well-- I said, you're, what, a 27-year-old white guy who grew up in a predominantly white area? I said, I don't know his life, but you haven't lived his life. You know, he's a 40-year-old Black guy who is living on the streets now. Who knows what the heck he's done? But look at-- what do you-- like, what do you see in me? What do you see here?
我说：“噢——你是，什么，一个在白人为主地区长大的 27 岁白人？我不了解他的生活，但你没过过他的生活。他是一个 40 岁的黑人，现在流落街头。谁知道他经历过什么鬼？但看看——你——你从我身上看到了什么？你在这里看到了什么？”
And it started to become a very heated and passionate discussion. Then I said, look at me, dark-skinned, blah, blah, blah. What do you see? And he's like, he started to get to my point, you know, and I just blurted it out. I said, I don't know if my mom [BLEEP] some Black guy or some Mexican guy. I said, but this is me. I have a different reality.
那演变成了一场非常激烈和充满激情的争论。然后我说：“看看我，皮肤深色，巴拉巴拉。你看到了什么？”他开始明白我的意思了，我脱口而出：“我不知道我妈是不是和哪个黑人或墨西哥人上过床。但这就是我。我有不同的现实。”
And when that came out of your mouth, what did you--
当那话从你嘴里说出来时，你——
When that came out of my mouth, like, you know-- I don't know how to even describe it. You know, it's just one of those things where you just, like-- did I just say that?
当它从我嘴里出来时，你知道——我不知道怎么形容。就像，你只是——我刚才说了吗？
So David had to talk to his mom, but he was terrified, terrified of unraveling a whole family built on the premise of one mom, one dad. Even though they'd gotten divorced years before, this seemed like a cataclysmic rewriting of history. So he waited two whole years and tried not to think about it.
所以大卫必须和妈妈谈谈，但他很害怕，害怕拆散一个建立在“一个母亲，一个父亲”前提下的家庭。尽管他们几年前已经离婚，但这似乎是一次灾难性的历史重写。于是他等了整整两年，尽量不去想它。
And then, one morning, he drove to his mom's house without telling her why. When he got there, David realized he had no prepared script. So he exchanged a few pleasantries, and he plunged. He said, simply, I need to know where I come from. Carol paused, looked at him, and responded, and you deserve to know.
后来一个早晨，他没说明原因就开车去了妈妈家。到了那里，大卫意识到自己没有任何准备好的稿子。所以他客套了几句，然后直奔主题。他只是简单地说：“我需要知道我来自哪里。”卡罗尔顿了顿，看着他，回答说：“你理应知道。”
In that moment, you know, I don't know. It's like a lifetime happened. And then, it was just like, OK. And she said, Dave Paladino is not your biological father.
那一刻，我不知道，好像经历了一生。然后，就是：“好的。”她说：“戴夫·帕拉迪诺不是你的亲生父亲。”
The next thing, please. [CHUCKLES] And she's like, your father is a man by the name of Keith Rash, who we went to high school with, and he's Black. And then, my mom said, no surprise to you.
“接下来呢，请说。[轻笑]”她说：“你的父亲是一个叫基思·拉什的人，我们和他高中同学，他是黑人。”然后我妈说：“你一点也不惊讶。”
With those words, Dave said it was like a symphony surged through his brain. It was a breakthrough and a relief. And contrary to his mom's fears, David wasn't angry with her at all.
听到这些话，戴夫说感觉就像一股交响乐在他脑海中激荡。这是一种突破和解脱。与他妈妈的恐惧相反，大卫一点也不生她的气。
He felt like he wasn't emotionally ready to know the truth after struggling personally in college and in the years after, until that very day. He actually felt grateful she waited. He was, though, worried about what David Sr. would do.
他觉得自己在大学里和之后几年的个人挣扎中，在情感上并没有准备好面对真相，直到那一天。他实际上很感激她等待了那么久。但他确实担心大卫·老帕拉迪诺会怎么做。
Turns out, Carol said, David Sr. had known for nine years. She had told him before their divorce, and begged him not to tell his son. David Sr. wasn't surprised. He said he always knew somehow, below the surface of consciousness.
事实证明，卡罗尔说，大卫·老帕拉迪诺九年前就已经知道了。她在离婚前告诉了他，并恳求他不要告诉儿子。大卫·老帕拉迪诺并不惊讶。他说他潜意识里一直都知道。
There's a principle in science called Occam's Razor. The idea is, if there are two possible explanations for some phenomenon, the simpler one is the better one to use. This principle goes back to Aristotle, who said, essentially, nature operates in the shortest way possible.
科学中有一个原理叫“奥卡姆剃刀”。其观点是，如果对某种现象有两种可能的解释，简单的那个通常更好。这个原理可以追溯到亚里士多德，他基本上说，大自然以尽可能最简单的方式运作。
And in our daily lives, this is how we usually explain the world to ourselves. But the simple explanation isn't always the one we want. The Paladinos couldn't accept the plain answer that Dave had a different father.
在日常生活中，我们通常就是这样向自己解释世界的。但简单的解释并不总是我们想要的。帕拉迪诺一家无法接受戴夫有另一个父亲这个平淡的事实。
They had to create something far more complex. What started a Carol's small secret simply grew too big to untangle. When David was born, she believed he was her husband's son, and when David Sr. believed that, too, months, and even years later, she thought to herself, why shatter that relationship?
他们不得不创造出更加复杂的东西。卡罗尔最初的一个小秘密变得太庞大，无法理清。当戴夫出生时，她相信他是丈夫的儿子；而当戴夫·老帕拉迪诺几个月甚至几年后也这么相信时，她想：“为什么要打破这段关系呢？”
She was so busy with three kids, she could often forget about David's coloring, sometimes even convincing herself that he might be her husband's anyway, that maybe there was something to that recessive gene idea. David Sr. did a similar dance, pushing disturbing questions out of his mind, because subconsciously, he wanted his family, his world, to remain intact.
她忙于三个孩子，常常忘记大卫的肤色，有时甚至说服自己他可能确实是丈夫的孩子，也许那关于隐性基因的说法有一定道理。大卫·老帕拉迪诺跳着同样的舞蹈，把令人不安的问题压在心底，因为潜意识里，他希望他的家庭、他的世界保持完整。
And the kids, like all kids, crave security, so they kept their questions buried, too. It wasn't that love was blind. It was that everyone was blinded by the fear of losing love.
而孩子们，像所有孩子一样，渴望安全感，所以他们也把疑问埋在心底。并不是爱蒙蔽了双眼，而是每个人都被失去爱的恐惧蒙蔽了。
No one wants to disturb the fragile bonds that keep us standing. Dave says a lot of people don't get this, don't understand why his family didn't always know he was Black.
没有人想破坏维系我们站立的脆弱纽带。戴夫说很多人不明白这一点，不明白为什么他的家庭没能一直知道他是黑人。
That's what people may not understand. Oh, yeah, Dave, well, I can tell you he's Black, or he's dark, or he's this. You know, [INAUDIBLE] those things are obvious, or I knew the whole time.
那是人们可能不理解的地方。“哦，是啊，戴夫，我可以告诉你他是黑人，或者他肤色深，或者他是这样。你知道，那些东西很明显，或者我早就知道了。”
Like, go screw yourself. Because the fact of the matter is is when you're in a situation and all you know is he's your dad and he's your son, and you know, I have support and I have love, you know, you're not looking to try and ruin that, or to-- you may have some questions. We may have been in denial. Not may have-- we were, or whatever, to a certain degree. But you know what you know.
比如，“去你的吧”。因为事实是，当你身处其中，你只知道他是你爸爸，你是他儿子，你知道我有支持，我有爱，你不会想要毁掉它，或者——你可能有一些疑问。我们可能曾处于否认之中。不是可能——我们确实是，或者以某种程度在否认。但你知道你知道的。
As you might expect, David wanted to meet his biological father. He started looking up Keith Rashes in telephone directories and calling them up. After months of reaching confused guys of all races, David finally tracked him down to an address on an Edgware Street in Memphis, Tennessee, no phone number available.
如你所料，大卫想见他的亲生父亲。他开始在电话簿里查找所有叫基思·拉什的人并逐一打电话。在接触了各种族困惑的家伙们几个月后，大卫终于查到了他在田纳西州孟菲斯埃奇威尔街的一个地址，没有电话号码。
David then avoided the issue again for six months, until he found himself in Florida on a job and decided to rent a car and drive 12 hours across five states in the rain. He found Edgware Street a little after 9:00 on a May morning.
大卫此后再次回避了这个问题六个月，直到他在佛罗里达工作时决定租辆车，在雨中穿越五个州开了 12 个小时的车。他在 5 月的一个早晨 9 点多找到了埃奇威尔街。
So I went to the front door-- [IMITATES KNOCKING] I knock on the front door. And I hear, around the corner, the side door open. Can I help you?
我走到前门——（模仿敲门声）我敲了敲前门。我听到拐角处侧门开了。“需要帮忙吗？”
Oh, man. Of course, my heart jumps into my throat. And I was like, what am I doing? And there's a man holding the screen door open.
天哪。当然，我的心跳到了嗓子眼。我心想：“我在干嘛？”有个男人正扶着纱门。
As soon as I come around the corner and I see this man, I'm like, oh my god, if that is not my father, I don't know who is. And I said, well-- I said, I'm looking for Keith Rash. And he says, you got him. Who are you?
当我绕过拐角看到这个男人时，我想：“天哪，如果那不是我父亲，我不知道是谁了。”我说：“我正在找基思·拉什。”他说：“就是我。你是谁？”
And I said, well, my name's David Paladino. And he looks at me. It's the strangest look on his face. He said, didn't I go to high school with you?
我说：“我叫大卫·帕拉迪诺。”他看着我。他脸上那种表情最奇怪。他说：“我不是和你高中同学过吗？”
And I'm like, um, no, not exactly. I said, maybe you remember my mom, Carol Provenzano. And I'll never forget it.
我说：“嗯，不，不完全是。也许你记得我妈妈，卡罗尔·普罗文扎诺。”我永远不会忘记那一幕。
He's got his one hand, like, keeping the door propped open, and he starts to turn in, like, to go in. And while he's turning in, he says, come on in. When he turned to go in, and I saw his legs and his shoulders, and just, almost the way he walked, because he had a bum knee, all the times that I looked for family members-- oh, do they look like me? Is that like me, or is that-- all of a sudden, I was looking at, like, my legs.
他一只手扶着门，开始转身往里走。当他转身往里走时，我说：“进来吧。”当我看到他的腿和肩膀，甚至他走路的样子，因为他膝盖有伤，所有那些我寻找亲人的时光——“他们长得像我吗？那像我吗，或者那——”突然之间，我看到的是——就像我的腿一样。
Keith Rash moved to Memphis about 18 years ago, and now works a security night shift at the FedEx hub. A few months ago, David and I went to Memphis to visit Keith. He's a gregarious, smiley guy, eager to please and excited that he has this brand-new son.
基思·拉什大约 18 年前搬到孟菲斯，现在在联邦快递中心做夜班保安。几个月前，大卫和我去孟菲斯探望基思。他是一个热情、爱笑的家伙，急于讨好，很高兴自己有了一个全新的儿子。
His apartment is almost entirely bare, save for a dining room table, a bed, and some empty boxes, and framed photographs everywhere. Underneath the bed and in the closet, there are more pictures, boxes and boxes of them, in albums and in bags.
他的公寓几乎空空如也，只有一张餐桌、一张床和几个空盒子，到处都是相框照片。在床底下和衣柜里还有更多照片，相册里、袋子里装了一盒又一盒。
Now, this-- this guy here, you see the resemblance?
“现在这个——这个家伙，你看长得像吗？”
Yes. Absolutely.
“是的，绝对像。”
But yeah, I think him and David look a lot alike.
“是的，我觉得他和大卫长得很像。”
They do.
“确实。”
Yeah, that's-- this is Henry Rash. He's from--
“是的，那是——这是亨利·拉什。他来自——”
In the time since his first trip to Memphis, Dave has been welcomed into the Rash family. He's met his half-brother and the rest of the family at a reunion in Chicago. He's making plans to spend some time with his grandmother in the next few months in Los Angeles.
自从第一次孟菲斯之旅以来，戴夫已经受到了拉什家族的欢迎。他在芝加哥的聚会上见到了同父异母的兄弟和家里的其他人。他正计划在未来几个月在洛杉矶和祖母待上一段时间。
Keith gushes and fawns over Dave, bragging about his acting gigs and comparing his good looks to his other son, Shelly. He says they're practically identical. Shelly was raised by his mom across the country, though he would visit Keith sometimes.
基思对戴夫赞不绝口，夸奖他的表演工作，并把他帅气的长相和另一个儿子雪莉相比。他说他们简直一模一样。雪莉是由他妈妈在全国另一边抚养长大的，尽管他偶尔会来看基思。
Keith shows us photos and tells us stories about his past. There are a lot of people who have died or who he's lost touch with, and he alludes to difficult years and a few run-ins with the law. Now, he says, he lives through his two sons, and he doesn't have many friends or much of a life in Memphis.
基思给我们看照片，讲他过去的故事。有很多他失去联系的人或者已经去世的人，他提到了艰难的岁月和一些与法律的冲突。现在，他说，他通过两个儿子生活，在孟菲斯他没有多少朋友，也没有什么生活。
He's more stable, mostly watches television, has a few drinks after work. Dave also brought pictures to show Keith. He pulls out a baby picture and some kid shots with his sisters.
他现在更稳定了，大多是看电视，下班后喝几杯。戴夫也带了照片给基思看。他拿出一张婴儿照和几张他和姐妹小时候的照片。
A couple here, when I was just a little, little man.
“几张在这儿，我还是个小不点儿的时候。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Ooh, wee. Yeah. Yeah, I'll tell you. You do look a little Afro-American on that, doesn't he, compared to-- yeah.
“噢，哇。是啊。是啊，我告诉你，你看起来确实有点非裔美国人的样子，不是吗，相比于——是啊。”
We decide to go out for some barbecue. Keith lets Dave borrow his special Year of the Dragon necklace, and keeps clapping him on the back. David is a little shyer, more watchful.
我们决定出去吃点烤肉。基思让戴夫借戴他那条特别的“龙年”项链，并不停地拍他的背。大卫稍微腼腆一点，更警觉一点。
On the way, I get this glimpse of what Keith is like. His personality is huge. He's funny and charming. He won't call me my first name, Cris, or my last name, Beam, but Beamer. It's hard not to like him.
路上，我对基思有了点了解。他的个性非常张扬。他很有趣，很有魅力。他不叫我名字克里斯或姓氏比姆，而是叫“比默”。很难不喜欢他。
While we're out, the waitress seems to take a shine to Keith, and he, slowly easing his eyes over the rim of his whiskey glass, tries to pick her up, right in front of his son and a radio reporter with a foot-long microphone.
在我们外面吃饭时，女服务员似乎挺喜欢基思，而他慢悠悠地透过威士忌杯的边缘看着她，试图搭讪，就在他儿子和拿着一英尺长麦克风的电台记者面前。
So that means you're going to be busy later.
“所以这意味着你待会会很忙。”
Mm.
“嗯。”
See, the reason I ask-- let me just cut to the chase.
“你看，我问的原因是——让我直接开门见山吧。”
That's right. [INAUDIBLE]
“没错。[难以听清]”
We're going back by my house. I'm taking off from FedEx tonight.
“我们要回我家。我今晚在联邦快递不上班。”
OK.
“好的。”
And I thought it'd be nice if you might come by and keep this going here.
“我觉得如果你能过来让这气氛继续下去，那会很好。”
Why not?
“为什么不呢？”
[MUSIC - "HEARTZ OF MEN" BY TUPAC]
[音乐 - 图派克的《男人之心》]
We go back to Keith's apartment and listen to music, drink some beers, and hang out. Keith raps along with Tupac. Dave hilariously practices his trained ballet moves to the beat in the middle of the living room. The waitress calls and flirts, but never shows up.
我们回到基思的公寓，听音乐，喝啤酒，待在一起。基思跟着图派克的节奏饶舌。戴夫在客厅中间滑稽地练习着他受过的芭蕾动作。那个女服务员打来电话调情，但一直没出现。
(RAPPING ALONG) It gets worse!
（跟着饶舌）“情况变糟了！”
Keith's fine with the fact that he didn't raise Dave. He implies that he might not have always been the best influence himself. And if he has a problem with the fact that Dave grew up in a white world with no strong Black figures to guide him, he doesn't let on. He says Carol and David provided Dave with the strength of character to handle it.
基思很坦然接受了他没抚养戴夫的事实。他暗示自己当初可能本身就不是最好的榜样。如果他对于戴夫是在一个白人世界里长大、没有强有力的黑人榜样引导而感到困扰，他也没表现出来。他说卡罗尔和大卫给了戴夫足够坚韧的性格去应对这一切。
Do you feel weird that they didn't tell him of his racial heritage at all? That he grew up thinking he was that he was white, and then struggling with that difference?
“你是否觉得他们根本没告诉他种族血统很奇怪？他长大后一直以为自己是白人，然后又在那种差异中挣扎？”
No, because it's got to go back to the family. If you got something that's been that deep-rooted for so long, why uproot it?
“不，因为那得回归到家庭本身。如果你有某种扎根那么深的东西，为什么要连根拔起呢？”
For his part, Dave has had two years now to adapt to the fact that he's Black, and he's still adjusting. It's awkward sometimes. He says there are some things he never learned or got used to.
就戴夫而言，他已经有两年时间去适应自己是黑人的事实，但他仍在调整。有时会觉得尴尬。他说有些事情他从来没学过，或者没习惯。
Because-- just the mechanics of not ever really being around a whole lot of Black people, and when I'm ever around more than probably three or maybe four, or like a bigger group, then I'm-- not like I'm crawling in my skin, but that I'm just not as solid as I am sitting here right now.
因为——只是因为从来没有真正和大量黑人待在一起的机制，当我周围的人超过三个或四个，或者像是一个更大的群体时，我就——不是说我感到浑身不自在，但我就是没有像现在坐在这里时那么踏实。
So you're nervous.
所以你很紧张。
Uh, I mean, it's not like I'm sitting there the whole time, kvetching, you know, oh my god. But I'm like-- I'm just not as settled all the time.
呃，我的意思是，并不是我一直坐在那儿发牢骚，你知道，噢，天哪。但我就是——我没有一直那么安定。
You know, I'm not as present or as centered as I am, like, sitting here talking. I think that somebody who's known all their life that they're half-this and half-that probably has more of an identity, maybe?
你知道，我没有像现在这样坐着说话时那么在状态或那么中心感。我觉得一个从小就知道自己是一半这个一半那个的人，可能自我认同感更强一点？
What's amazing about this story is that nobody's mad. Keith's not bitter that he had no access to his son. David's not mad at his mother and never has been. Even Dave Sr. isn't angry. He still feels just as much David's father as he ever did, which brings us back to Occam's Razor, the principle that the simplest explanation for something is the best one.
这个故事最神奇的地方在于没有人发火。基思并没有因为没能抚养儿子而愤愤不平。大卫没有生他母亲的气，也从未生过。连老戴维都不生气。他依然觉得自己和大卫的父子关系和以前一样，这就把我们带回了奥卡姆剃刀，那个认为最简单的解释就是最好的解释的原理。
In a family, the explanation that seems simplest can switch over time. When David was young, the simpler thing to believe was that his parents were his parents and his family was his family, and that he was a Paladino. As he got older, that story got harder to maintain, and the other explanation, that Keith was his father, became the simplest for everyone.
在家庭中，看起来最简单的解释会随时间推移而改变。大卫年轻时，最简单的解释就是父母是他的父母，家庭是他的家庭，他就是个帕拉迪诺。随着年龄增长，那个故事变得难以维持，而另一种解释——基思是他父亲——对每个人来说都成了最简单的。
And when the family shifted from one story to the other, they didn't get caught up in issues of race, and paternity, and lying, and betrayal. When the truth came out, the truth that the whole family was fearing for so long, it didn't spark any great drama at all. It just put people at peace.
当家庭从一个故事转向另一个故事时，他们并没有陷入种族、血缘、谎言和背叛的问题中。当真相大白，那个全家恐惧了那么久的真相，并没有引发任何戏剧性的冲突。它只是让人们内心平静。
Cris Beam in Los Angeles.
洛杉矶的克里斯·比姆报道。
Coming up, David Sedaris conducts an experiment with fluids and heat in a 2-and-1/2-foot tube. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯将在一个 2 英尺半的管子里进行一项关于流体和热量的实验。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Family Physics, stories of everyday life which we come to understand better by applying the laws and principles of science. We have arrived at act two of our program, Act Two, The Trajectory and Force of Bodies in Orbit.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来一系列关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“家庭物理学”，我们通过应用科学定律和原理来更好地理解日常生活。现在我们来到了节目的第二幕：轨道中物体的轨迹与力。
Jon Ronson is a writer living in England. He does an occasional documentary story for British television. And he tells this modest story of the universal laws which govern our daily behavior. In it, he is in a reluctant orbit around his parents, and his parents are in a rather energetic orbit, around, well, you'll see.
乔恩·朗森是一位住在英国的作家。他偶尔为英国电视做纪录片报道。他讲述了这个关于支配我们日常行为的普遍定律的简单故事。在故事中，他正处于对他父母的一种不情愿的轨道中，而他的父母则围绕着，嗯，你会看到的。
My family runs a hotel in the Brecon Beacons mountain range of mid-Wales. I go home to the hotel every Christmas, and at some point, I always manage to say, I treat this place just like a hotel, and this always gets a big laugh.
我家人在威尔士中部的布雷肯比肯斯山脉经营一家旅馆。我每年圣诞节都会回旅馆，在某个时刻，我总是忍不住说：“我像对待旅馆一样对待这个地方”，这总是会引起一阵大笑。
Sometimes, famous people stay at the hotel, too, which my parents treat as a perk of the job. My mother always calls me up when it happens. When the British TV news reporter, John Cole, was there recently, my mother phoned me up and said, guess what? John Cole's staying here! Oh, and he hasn't heard of you!
有时名人也会住在旅馆里，我父母把这视为工作的福利。每当这时，我母亲总是给我打电话。英国电视新闻记者约翰·科尔最近住在那里时，我妈打电话来说：“猜猜怎么着？约翰·科尔住在这里！噢，他没听说过你！”
A few years ago, John Birt, the Director General of the BBC, came in to have lunch. My father approached his table. Are you John Birt? He asked. Yes, said Jon Birt.
几年前，BBC 总干事约翰·伯特进来吃午饭。我父亲走近他的桌子。“你是约翰·伯特吗？”他问。“是的，”约翰·伯特说。
I wonder if you can help, said my father. The TV reception in this area can be all crackly and fuzzy. Is there anything you can do about this? I think my father wanted John Birt to get onto the roof and fix the aerial.
“我想知道你能不能帮个忙，”我父亲说，“这个地区的电视接收信号总是吱吱响又模糊。你有什么办法吗？”我想我父亲是想让约翰·伯特爬上屋顶去修理天线。
We spoke about all sorts, my father told me on the phone afterwards, the problems I'm having with my car. He couldn't believe it's been in the garage six times. Oh, and he hasn't heard of you, added my mother on the extension line.
“我们聊了很多，我车子遇到的那些问题，”我父亲事后在电话里告诉我，“他简直不敢相信这车已经进车库修过六次了。”“噢，他没听说过你，”我母亲在分机上补充道。
Recently, my parents won the coveted Welsh Hotel of the Year competition. It was a big honor, and they wanted to do something to commemorate the success. So they decided to commission a portrait painter to immortalize the Ronsons.
最近，我父母赢得了令人垂涎的“威尔士年度酒店”大赛。这是一个巨大的荣誉，他们想做点什么来纪念这份成功。于是他们决定委托一位肖像画家将朗森一家永恒地定格下来。
We've decided to have a group family portrait commissioned, said my mother on the phone, a Ronson family portrait to be hung in the bar. Will you be available for a sitting? Certainly, I said. Who's doing it?
“我们决定委托画一幅家族群像，”我母亲在电话里说，“一幅朗森家族肖像，要挂在酒吧里。你有空来当模特吗？”“当然，”我说，“谁来画？”
He's a brilliant but troubled local artist, she said. He did the mural for the new Cardiff multiplex. You must have heard of it. No, I said. Oh, come on! She said. It's been in all the papers. Anyway, he paints hotels, too. He came up to ask us if we wanted ours painted.
“他是一位出色但烦恼缠身的当地艺术家，”她说，“他为卡迪夫新开的多厅影院画了壁画。你一定听说过。”“没有，”我说。“噢，得了吧！”她说，“报纸上都登了。总之，他也画酒店。他来问我们想不想把我们的酒店画下来。”
You mean, he depicts hotels on canvas? I asked. Oh, no, no, she said. He actually paints the walls of hotels. So he's a painter and a decorator? I asked. What's your problem? Said my mother. Are you being snooty?
“你是说，他把酒店画在画布上？”我问。“哦，不，不，”她说，“他实际上是在粉刷酒店墙壁。”“所以他是个油漆工和装饰工？”我问。“你有什么毛病？”我妈说，“你在摆架子吗？”
It turned out that the brilliant but troubled artist's particular subspecialty is painting celebrities in classical Renaissance settings, like Clint Eastwood ascending to heaven surrounded by angels. His loving recreations of celebrities set my parents thinking, so many famous people stay at their hotel. What if the Ronson family portrait was extended to include celebrities?
事实证明，那位出色但烦恼缠身的艺术家的特长是把名人画在古典文艺复兴背景中，比如克林特·伊斯特伍德在天使环绕中升天。他充满爱意地还原名人，让我的父母陷入了沉思：那么多名人都住在他们的酒店里。如果朗森家族的肖像画里也包含名人会怎么样？
Listen to this, said my mother on the phone the next day. We, the family, will be standing in the grounds of the hotel, surrounded by famous people. Which famous people? I asked. You mean, the famous people who've stayed at the hotel?
“听这个，”第二天我妈妈在电话里说，“我们，家人，将站在旅馆的场地上，被名人包围。”“哪些名人？”我问，“你是说，住过旅馆的那些名人吗？”
Oh, no, said my mother. Any famous people that we choose. I fell silent on the other end of the phone, trying to let the incredible of this proposed project sink in. My mother carried on.
“哦，不，”我妈说，“我们挑选任何名人。”我在电话这头沉默了，试图让这个提议中的宏伟项目沉淀下来。我妈继续说道。
She said, we're working on a tight deadline. Send a Polaroid of yourself to the artist. You have to come up with your three famous people by Wednesday-- living or dead, comedian, statesmen, actors, anything.
她说：“我们的截止日期很紧。把你的一张宝丽来照片寄给艺术家。周三之前你必须选出你的三个名人——活着的或死去的，喜剧演员、政治家、演员，什么都行。”
Let me clarify this in my head, I said. There's nothing to clarify! Said my mother. Don't you think it may come across as a little self-aggrandizing? I asked.
“让我整理一下思绪，”我说。“没什么好整理的！”我妈说。“你不觉得这看起来有点自我膨胀吗？”我问。
I'm choosing President Kennedy, Gandhi, and Churchill, said my mother. My father came onto the phone. Who are you choosing? I asked him. Gary Player, Arnold Palmer, and Jack Nicklaus, he said. All golfers? I asked.
“我选择了肯尼迪总统、甘地和丘吉尔，”我妈说。我父亲接过了电话。“你选择了谁？”我问他。“加里·普莱尔、阿诺德·帕尔默和杰克·尼克劳斯，”他说。“都是高尔夫球手？”我问。
Who are you choosing? Asked my father. My mind drew a blank. In fact, I began to panic. I imagined, in hundreds of years' time, notable art historians gathered around the painting, making sarcastic comments.
“你选择了谁？”我父亲问。我的大脑一片空白。事实上，我开始恐慌。我想象着在几百年后，著名的艺术历史学家聚集在画作前，发表讽刺评论。
Paintings are so permanent. I was to be frozen in time for eternity with three celebrities. And now, the question was, which celebrities best represented Jon Ronson's essence? It was easy for my father.
画作是如此永久。我将与三位名人一起被冰封在永恒中。而现在的问题是，哪位名人最能代表乔恩·朗森的本质？我父亲很容易。
It was as if each of his three golfers portrayed a different subtlety to his personality. There was Arnold Palmer, the kind and thoughtful golfer with the common touch. There was Jack Nicklaus, the fiery, steely golfer who once said, nobody ever remembers who finished second at anything. And there was Gary Player, the philosophical golfer whose 10 commandments for life, as seen on GaryPlayer.com, includes, the fox fears not the man who boasts by night, but the man who rises early in the morning.
就好像他的三位高尔夫球手分别描绘了他个性的不同细微之处。有阿诺德·帕尔默，那位拥有平民情怀的善良而体贴的高尔夫球手。有杰克·尼克劳斯，那位炽热而坚定、曾说“没人会记得任何事情的亚军”的高尔夫球手。还有加里·普莱尔，那位哲学高尔夫球手，他在 GaryPlayer.com 上列出的生活十大准则包括：“狐狸不怕彻夜吹牛的人，但怕清晨早起的人。”
But who could I choose? I found myself feeling hostile to the whole idea, a hostility that manifested itself in a lazy choice of celebrities. I'm going for The Beverley Sisters, I told my mother on the phone.
但我能选谁呢？我发现自己对整个想法感到敌意，这种敌意表现为懒散地选择了名人。“我选比弗利姐妹，”我在电话里告诉妈妈。
I actually have no interest in girl groups of the 1940s, but I did know that The Beverley Sisters all looked exactly alike, and my choice was designed to be viewed by art historians of the future as an ironic silent protest. You can't have The Beverley Sisters, said my mother, knowing me well enough to understand all of this in an instant.
其实我对 1940 年代的女子组合毫无兴趣，但我确实知道比弗利姐妹长得一模一样，我的选择旨在被未来的艺术历史学家视为一种讽刺性的无声抗议。“你不能选比弗利姐妹，”我妈说，她足够了解我，瞬间就明白了这一切。
How about Sister Sledge? I said. Are you trying to ruin this? Said my mother. I relented and opted for my real all-time celebrity hero. Randy Newman, I said.
“选 Sister Sledge 怎么样？”我说。“你想毁掉这一切吗？”我妈说。我妥协了，选择了真正的终身偶像。“兰迪·纽曼，”我说。
Nobody knows what Randy Newman looks like! She snapped. In the end, we compromised. For all time, it would be Jon Ronson, Ike and Tina Turner, and Boris Yeltsin.
“没人知道兰迪·纽曼长什么样！”她吼道。最后，我们妥协了。直到永远，那幅画里将是乔恩·朗森、艾克和蒂娜·特纳以及鲍里斯·叶利钦。
The Ronsons were going to be hobnobbing amongst the stars. The laws of physics tells us that one needs to be very careful approaching a star. If your trajectory and speed are just right, you'll go into orbit, safe and sound, glowing in the warm, beautiful starlight.
朗森一家将要在群星中流连忘返。物理定律告诉我们，靠近恒星时需要非常小心。如果你的轨迹和速度恰到好处，你就会进入轨道，安然无恙，在温暖美丽的星光中发光。
If you mess up in any way, the wrong direction, the wrong speed, you'll hurtle into the face of the star and be vaporized. And only the star will remain. My parents were involving us in a very dangerous game.
如果你有任何失误，方向不对，速度不对，你就会撞向恒星表面被汽化。只有恒星会留下来。我的父母正让我们参与一场非常危险的游戏。
A few days later, my mother called to tell me that the concept had slightly changed. Each Ronson, she said, would no longer be just standing and chatting to the celebrities. We were to be serving them drinks.
几天后，我母亲打电话告诉我，方案稍微变了。她说，每个朗森成员不再只是站着和名人聊天。我们要为他们端酒。
This was, after all, a hotel. So now, I was to be frozen in time in an act of subservience to Boris Yeltsin. A few days later, the concept changed yet again. It was back to standing and chatting, but this time, the Ronsons would be talking, and the celebrities would be listening.
这毕竟是一家酒店。所以现在，我将在服侍鲍里斯·叶利钦的过程中被冰封在永恒中。几天后，方案又变了。又回到了站着聊天，但这次是朗森一家在说话，而名人们在倾听。
So you'll be talking? I clarified. And Kennedy, Gandhi, and Churchill will be listening? What's the problem? Said my mother. Oh, nothing, nothing, I said. I'm just worried that people may get the wrong idea, you know, that we consider ourselves as good as Kennedy and--
“所以你们在说话？”我澄清道，“肯尼迪、甘地和丘吉尔在听？”“有什么问题吗？”我妈说。“哦，没什么，没什么，”我说，“我只是担心人们可能会有错误的印象，你知道，我们认为自己和肯尼迪一样优秀，而且——”
What are you saying? Said my mother. Nothing, I said. I changed the subject. What will you be talking to Kennedy, Gandhi, and Churchill about? What do you mean, what will I be talking to them about? Said my mother.
“你在说什么？”我妈说。“没什么，”我说。我换了话题，“你会和肯尼迪、甘地和丘吉尔聊什么？”“你什么意思，我聊什么？”我妈说。
Nothing! I'm talking to them about nothing! It's a painting! Maybe Dad would be talking to the golfers about the amount of times his car has been in the garage, I suggested.
“没什么！我什么也没跟他们聊！那是一幅画！”“也许爸爸会跟那些高尔夫球手聊他车子进车库修过多少次，”我建议道。
I sent in my Polaroids, and we all waited. Months passed. My father would telephone the artist from time to time to find out how things were going, and when was it going to be finished. Most often, the artist didn't pick up. And when he did, he was a man of few words, words that were spoken gruffly.
我寄出了宝丽来照片，然后我们都在等待。几个月过去了。我父亲会时不时地给艺术家打电话，询问进展情况，什么时候完成。大多数时候，艺术家没接。即使接了，也是话很少，而且说得非常粗鲁。
Nearly there, he said. Are you pleased with it so far? Asked my father. Don't worry, said the artist. My father began to worry.
“快了，”他说。“到目前为止满意吗？”我父亲问。“别担心，”艺术家说。我父亲开始担心了。
The day of the grand unveiling came without warning. The artist just turned up one morning, carrying a large canvas covered in a white sheet. He propped it up against the bar. The family gathered around it with a sense of great expectation.
盛大的揭幕仪式毫无征兆地到来。艺术家某天早上突然出现了，带着一幅覆盖着白布的大画布。他把它靠在酒吧边。家人怀着巨大的期待聚集在周围。
Everyone looked at the covered painting and at the brilliant but troubled artist, trying to scrutinize his facial expression. It was, well, troubled. The artist said, I think you ought to know that I'm going through a creative stage, which some people find difficult to connect to.
每个人都看着覆盖的画作，看着那位出色但烦恼缠身的艺术家，试图审视他的面部表情。嗯，是烦恼。艺术家说：“我觉得你应该知道，我正在经历一个创意阶段，有些人觉得很难与之产生共鸣。”
There was a nervous silence. What I'm saying, he continued, is there's a possibility you may not like it. The Ronsons looked anxiously at one another.
出现了一阵紧张的沉默。“我的意思是，”他继续道，“你们有可能不会喜欢它。”朗森一家焦虑地看着对方。
Then, with a flourish, the artist whipped off the sheet. There you go, he said. For a moment, the Ronsons just stared. My mother whispered, oh my God.
然后，伴随着一声响动，艺术家猛地掀开了布。“好了，”他说。有一瞬间，朗森一家只是盯着看。我母亲低语道：“噢，天哪。”
She clutched her chest, yelped quietly, and stormed out of the room. My brother and his wife followed, as a show of unity, slamming the door behind them. The artist was left alone with my father.
她紧捂着胸口，轻声惊叫，怒气冲冲地跑出了房间。我的兄弟和他的妻子跟在后面，以示团结，摔门而去。艺术家和我父亲独处。
They didn't make eye contact. They just stared at the painting. The famous people had all been painted with tender accuracy. There were a few celebrities like Clint Eastwood that none of the Ronsons had actually asked for.
他们没有眼神交流，只是盯着那幅画。名人们都被刻画得十分精准细腻。还有一些像克林特·伊斯特伍德这样朗森家并没有要求的名人。
But that wasn't the problem. The problem was that although the celebrities were lovingly depicted, the Ronsons stood amongst them as human, grotesqueries, repulsive caricatures of monsters. My brother looked like Frankenstein. He had a bolt through his neck.
但这并不是问题所在。问题是，尽管名人们被刻画得充满爱意，但朗森一家站在他们中间却成了人类的怪胎，成了怪物的丑陋漫画。我兄弟看起来像科学怪人。他的脖子上插着一个螺栓。
It was disturbing and humiliating. My parents looked like hastily sketched recovering drug addicts. I looked like a gawky, spotty adolescent, frozen in a gormless pose.
这令人不安且羞辱。我父母看起来像匆忙画出来的康复中瘾君子。我看起来像个笨拙的、满脸斑点的少年，僵在一种呆滞的姿势中。
Sorry, said the painter, looking at the floor. We're not paying for it, said my father. There was a long silence. My father ordered the artist to paint the Ronsons out. And after much negotiation, he agreed.
“抱歉，”画家看着地板说。“我们不会付钱的，”我父亲说。长久的沉默。我父亲命令艺术家把朗森一家涂掉。经过多次协商，他同意了。
He turned my mother into Woody Allen. That's kind of humiliating in itself, that the easiest brush over would render her as Woody Allen. My father is Jimmy Carter. I like to think the artist chose Jimmy Carter, the famed peacemaker, to replace my dad in an homage to my father's diplomacy, as he was the only Ronson who didn't storm out.
他把我的母亲画成了伍迪·艾伦。这本身就够丢人的，最简单的覆盖方式竟让她变成了伍迪·艾伦。我父亲变成了吉米·卡特。我喜欢认为艺术家选择著名的和平缔造者吉米·卡特来代替我父亲，是向我父亲外交手腕的一种致敬，因为他是唯一一个没有冲出去的朗森。
My brother was turned into David Rockefeller, and his wife was turned into Henry Kissinger, which I interpret as an act of hostility. The only Ronson left in the portrait is, oddly, me. The painting now hangs between the cigarette machine and the coat stand of the bar in my family's hotel.
我兄弟变成了大卫·洛克菲勒，他的妻子变成了亨利·基辛格，我认为这是一种敌意行为。画作中剩下的唯一一个朗森，奇怪的是，是我。这幅画现在挂在我家酒店酒吧的香烟机和衣架之间。
And it's the cause of much interest amongst the customers. They crowd around it, trying to guess who everyone is. That's Kennedy, they say. Look, Boris Yeltsin! Nobody gets David Rockefeller. I have to say, it's David Rockefeller!
它引起了顾客们的极大兴趣。他们围在周围，试图猜每个人是谁。“那是肯尼迪，”他们说。“看，鲍里斯·叶利钦！”没人认出大卫·洛克菲勒。我不得不说：“那是大卫·洛克菲勒！”
Ah, they reply. David Rockefeller. They stare blankly at the likeness of me, too, for whole minutes at a time, trying to figure out who exactly I am. I'm famous! I say. I've been on TV.
“啊，”他们回答，“大卫·洛克菲勒。”他们又呆呆地盯着那幅画像看了足足几分钟，试图搞清楚我究竟是谁。“我是名人！”我说，“我上过电视。”
But they all just squint and shrug. If my mother is there, she'll cheerfully pipe in. Oh, they've never heard of you.
但他们全都只是眯着眼睛耸耸肩。如果我母亲在场，她会兴高采烈地插嘴：“噢，他们从没听说过你。”
Jon Ronson. He's the author of The Men Who Stare at Goats and other books.
乔恩·朗森。他是《凝视山羊的人》和其他书籍的作者。
[MUSIC - "STARS IN MY LIFE" BY THE FLATLANDERS]
[音乐 - 弗拉特兰德乐队的《我生命中的星辰》]
(SINGING) The stars in my life will shine like sunshine. If only I can see your smiling face. Though this universe collapses on occasion, the stars in my life will stay in place.
（演唱）“我生命中的星辰将像阳光一样闪耀。如果我能看见你微笑的脸。尽管宇宙偶尔会崩塌，但我生命中的星辰会留在原位。”
Act Three, Conservation of Matter and Energy. Matter and energy are different versions of each other. And while you can convert one into the other, they cannot be created or destroyed. David Sedaris was reminded of this basic principle of matter recently when he tried a personal experiment of his own with an accessory he bought himself.
第三幕，物质和能量守恒。物质和能量是彼此的不同版本。虽然你可以将一种转换为另一种，但它们不能被创造或摧毁。大卫·塞达里斯最近在尝试一项关于他为自己购买的某种配件的个人实验时，被提醒了这个物质的基本原理。
His story was recorded in front of a live audience by Seattle Arts and Lectures. Quick warning to the squeamish-- this story contains possibly sensitive content. There's nothing sexual or graphic, but some people might find it gross.
他的故事是由西雅图艺术与演讲厅在现场观众面前录制的。给敏感者一个小警告——这个故事包含可能敏感的内容。没有色情或露骨的东西，但有些人可能会觉得恶心。
I've always liked the idea of accessories. It was my search for something discreet, masculine, and practical that led me to the Stadium Pal, an external catheter currently being marketed to sports fans--
我一直很喜欢配饰的想法。正是因为寻找某种谨慎、阳刚且实用的东西，我找到了“体育伙伴”（Stadium Pal），一种目前正推销给体育迷的外置导尿管——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--truck drivers, and anyone else who's tired of searching for a bathroom.
——卡车司机，以及任何厌倦了寻找厕所的人。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
At first inspection, the device met all my criteria. Was it masculine? Yes. And proudly so. Unlike a regular catheter, which is inserted directly into the penis, the Stadium Pal connects by way of a self-adhesive condom, which is then attached to a flexible rubber tube.
初看之下，该设备符合我所有的标准。阳刚吗？是的。而且非常有。与插入阴茎内部的普通导尿管不同，“体育伙伴”是通过一个自粘避孕套连接的，然后连接到一根灵活的橡胶管上。
Urine flows through the tube and collects in the Freedom Leg Bag--
尿液流过管子，收集在“自由腿袋”里——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--conveniently attached to the user's calf. The bag can be emptied and reused up to 12 times, making it both disgusting and cost-effective.
——方便地系在用户的小腿上。这个袋子可以清空并重复使用多达 12 次，既恶心又省钱。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And what could be manlier?
还有什么比这更男人的吗？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Was it discreet? According to the brochure, unless you wore it with shorts--
隐蔽吗？根据小册子，除非你穿短裤——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--no one needed to know a thing about it. Was it practical? At the time, yes. I don't drive or attend football games, but I did have a book tour coming up.
——没人需要知道这件事。实用吗？当时是的。我不开车也不参加足球赛，但我有个新书巡回宣传活动。
And the possibilities were endless. Five glasses of iced tea, followed by a long public reading? Thanks, Stadium Pal.
可能性是无限的。喝五杯冰茶，接着参加一场冗长的公开朗读会？谢谢你，“体育伙伴”。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
The window seat on an overbooked cross-country flight? Don't mind if I do.
在超售的横跨全国的航班上坐靠窗位？我愿意试试。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I ordered myself a Stadium Pal, and realized that while it might make sense in a hospital, it really wasn't very practical for day-to-day use. In an open-air sporting arena, a piping hot 32-ounce bag of urine might go unnoticed.
我为自己订购了一个“体育伙伴”，并意识到虽然在医院里它可能很有道理，但它在日常生活中真的不太实用。在露天体育场，一袋滚烫的 32 盎司尿液可能不引人注意。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
But not so in a stuffy airplane--
但在闷热的飞机上——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--or a small, crowded bookstore. An hour after christening it, I smelled like a nursing home.
——或拥挤的小书店里就不行了。使用它一小时后，我闻起来就像个疗养院。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
On top of that, I found that it was hard to pee and do other things at the same time.
最重要的是，我发现很难一边小便一边做其他事情。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Reading out loud--
大声朗读——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--discussing my dinner options with a flight attendant--
——和空乘讨论晚餐选项——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--checking into a fine hotel. Each activity required its own separate form of concentration. And while no one knew exactly what I was up to, it was pretty clear that something was going on.
——登记入住高档酒店。每一项活动都需要各自的专注力。虽然没人确切知道我在干什么，但很明显有些不对劲。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I think it was my face that gave me away.
我想是我的表情出卖了我。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
That and my oddly swollen calf.
还有我那肿胀的小腿。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
What ultimately did me in was the self-adhesive condom.
最终摧毁我的是那个自粘避孕套。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Putting it on was no problem, but it's removal qualified as what in certain cultures is known as a bris.
戴上它没问题，但它的拆卸过程在某些文化中被称为“割礼”。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Wear it once, and you'll need a solid month in order to fully recover. It would likely be a month in which you'll weigh the relative freedom of peeing in your pants against the unsightly discomfort of a scab-covered penis.
戴一次，你就得花整整一个月才能完全恢复。这一个月里，你大概会在随地尿尿的自由和结痂阴茎的不适之间进行权衡。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
David Sedaris, who was recorded by Seattle Arts and Lectures. He is the author of many fine books, and he's out on the road these days, giving talks. To find out when he's coming to your town, visit DavidSedarisBooks.com
大卫·塞达里斯，由西雅图艺术与演讲厅录制。他著有许多好书，近来一直在路上进行巡回演讲。想知道他什么时候去你的城市，请访问 DavidSedarisBooks.com。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder.
好吧，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈德斯坦和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩。今天的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。
Contributing editors for today's show-- Susan Burton, Rebecca Carroll, Jack Hitt, Margie Rockland, Alix Spiegel, Paul Tough, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Music help today from Jamie Hodge and Sarah Vowell.
今天的特约编辑——苏珊·伯顿、丽贝卡·卡罗尔、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克兰、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、保罗·托夫、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。音乐支持来自杰米·霍奇和萨拉·沃威尔。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explained some recent decisions at the radio station this way.
我们的网站是 ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他以这种方式解释了电台最近的一些决定：
I think you ought to know that I'm going through a creative stage, which some people find difficult to connect to.
“我觉得你应该知道，我正在经历一个创意阶段，有些人觉得很难与之产生共鸣。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。